انا او عوده للموضوع الفلسطينيه والتصعيد
الاسرائيلي الجاري في الاراضي الفلسطينيه
معنا الان من البيت الابيض جون كاربي منسق
الاتصالات الاستراتيجيه في مجلس الامن
القومي الامريكي اهلا بك السيد جون كاربي
يعني لنبدا بهذا الموقف الامريكي جراء ما
اسماه الاعمال الاعمال العنف العشوائيه
للمستوطنين والتي راى فيها اورات فيها
الولايات المتحده بانها غير مقبوله هذه
الادانه الامريكيه اللافته المعلنه اليوم
من الولايات المتحده عن اي قراءه امريكيه
للمشهد تكشف هذه الادانه
نحن تحدثنا عن ذلك يوم امس وبالطبع نحن
نسجد كل انواع العنف هذا غير مقبول سمعتم
الشركاء
الاسرائيلين الرئيس
الوزراء
يقولون انه من غير مقبول ان يقوم المواطن
العادي باخذ انفاذ القانون بيده نحن لا
نريد رؤيه اي شكل من اشكالا نريد لاي احد
ان يتضرر ما نزال نرى ان
حلت دولتين ناجع ونريد ايضا
النشاط الاستيطاني ان يتوقف ويكون الحل
على اساس حاله دولتين اذا قلت تجيبون كل
انواع العنف سيد كاربي لكن ما هي الرؤيه
الامريكيه الترجمه الامريكيه لما يحدث من
تصعيد الان في الاراضي الفلسطينيه من قبل
العسكريه الاسرائيليه
نحن نريد للعنف ان ينتهي هذا واضح ونحن
نريد ايضا من كلا الطرفين ان يستمر في
العمل لساويه ليس فقط من اجل تخفيفه حده
التصعيد لكن ما زلنا نؤمن بان بالامكان
السعي للتحقيق حل على اساس حل الدولتان
واضح اننا لا نريد رؤيه اي من هذه الحوادث
من ان يتاثر ايضا من كلا الطرفين او تعيش
العائلات في خوف
الولايات المتحده دخلت الى اجتماعات
العقبه وهي تقدم ضمانات ما هي الضمانات
التي تقدمها الولايات المتحده
لكفي هذا العنف الجاري حاليا وهذه
العمليات المتدحرجه في الاراضي الفلسطينيه
ما كان مهما من نتائج اجتماعي العقبه هو
ان الاطراف قدمت التزامات امام بعضها
البعض الاخر للتخفيف من حده التوتر ووقف
العنف
والعنف في عطله نهايه الاسبوع راينا ان
القاده اجتمعوا في العقبه في عطلتها
الاسبوع وراينا عنفا قاتلا فقط هذا يشدد
على اهميه
الاطراف المجتمعه في العقبه لكي تبحث عن
طرق لتخفيف التوتر لن اترك الامر لهم
لبيان ما هو التقدم الذين يريدون تحقيقه
ونحن نعتقد ان القاده من كلا الطرفان
اضافه الى ملك عبد الله اهل الاردن
والرئيس السيسي رئيس مصر نشكرهم على جمع
هذه الاطراف سويه
لان هذه الطريقه بناء
تبين كيف يمكن لنا ان نخفف من حده التوتر
يعني اطلاق يد المستوطنين جاء بعد دقائق
من تفاهمات العقبه الا ترى واشنطن بان هذا
تقويض لجهودها التي قامت بها لاحتواء
الموقف
كلا الامر على عكس ذلك نحن نعتقد ان بسبب
الاحداث الكارثيه في عطله نهايه الاسبوع
هذا يضع التوكيد مره اخرى على اهميه
اجتماعي العقبه والبيان الذي تلاهوا
والالتزام المتبادل من كلا الطرفين لتخفيف
التوتر والتصعيد وللبحث عن سبل للعمل سويه
بشكل افضل لاخذ هذه العمليه الى الامام
اذا وفي الوقت الذي لا يغيب عن انظارنا ان
هذا العنف حدث في اعقاب بيان صدور بيان
العقبه هذا ايضا يشدد مره اخرى لنا على
اهميه الحوار
والتواصل
والعقد اللقاءات وجها لوجه التخفيف من هذه
المشكله لكن يعني سيد تربيه هذه التطورات
اظهرت بان بان هناك حاجه لضمانات لضمان
تنفيذ هذه
الالتزامات التي تم التوصل اليها ما هو
دور امريكا حاليا في تقديم هذه الضمانات
الرئيس بايدن ملتزم
بالمضي قدما الى الامام
ولمحاوله حل دولتين قابل للاستمرار لان في
وجهه نظر الرئيس هذا هو المسار الحقيقي
للسلام وهو يؤمن بان هذا ممكن انتم تحدثتم
عن الالتزام الالتزام مطلوب من كلا
الطرفين عليهما وعلى قدر المتساوي ان
يكونا ملتزمين بحاله دولتان لقاء العقبه
والبيان الذي صدر في عطله نهايه الاسبوع
الماضي كان كما وصفته نقطه بدايه جيده
وخطوه جيده الى الامام ونحن نود رؤيه
خطوات اضافيه من كلا الطرفين وكلا الطرفان
عندما يتخذان هذه الخطوات لن يجد صديقا
افضل من الولايات المتحده لدعمهما لكن
الامر يحتاج روح قياديه من كلا الطرفين
وراينا كيف نلقاها العقبه كان بدايه جيده
لكن نقليه الالتزام بهذه الخطوات التي
تطالب بها الولايات المتحده الى الطرفين
لابد من اوراق ربما تستخدم امريكيا للضغط
على كلا الاطراف ما هي الاوراق بيد
الولايات المتحده لتنفيذ مثل هذه
الالتزامات والمضي قدما كما تقول